how do you break the addiction of
wanting to compete with others because
you believe you deserve what they have
hmm well I've got a I've got a short but
rather practical answer and then we
could talk about it here my my pithy
answer is some cultures consider
competition to be a mental illness and
well I wouldn't go that far and say all
competition is of mental illness I'd
like to delineate different types of
competition they're just like obsession
there is healthy competition like if you
and I were to go play well we play ping
pong all the time yes and it's a healthy
competition and and there's nothing like
hateful there's nothing that's addictive
about it like we're both aggressively
average at ping pong and we think we're
way better than we actually oh yeah yeah
and and and you're probably slightly
better than me but sometimes I will beat
you in fact maybe 51% of the time I'll
beat you because I think I might try 1%
harder or something
but the point is like it is a friendly
competition the pernicious competition
is thinking that you're in a competition
when you actually aren't right when all
of a sudden it's like oh they have a
Lamborghini and I just have our
mercedes-benz I am clearly losing yeah
this competition they don't even know
they're competing with you you're
competing against some imaginary figure
in your head and the reason that I I use
this pithy answer if some cultures
consider competition to be a mental
illness I learned this when we were
living in Montana right I would
occasionally do the sauna at the YMCA
but with folks from the Blackfoot Indian
tribe there and one of the folks there
talked to me about like it's weird how
Westerners think of like if it's a
win-lose zero-sum game right whereas in
our tribe we think of it as a mental
illness like if there's a person who's
being competitive then there's something
wrong with them mentally and we need to
like find a way to help them understand
that if you win I win yeah and if you're
losing I'm
and and that's what's going on with the
previous question from Luis is ladies
family is feeling that actual loss of
late
well he's losing so we're losing and and
when you think about it that way you
realize like oh the people around me if
they're winning then I'm also winning
yeah man and how good does that feel and
then you work as a team because you want
to help each other win and well I think
I'm gonna save this next bit for our
next question Ryan what's your pithy
answer cool I'd say there's no need to
compete with the Joneses if you're
living up to your personal standards if
you still feel incomplete raise your
standards I mean when I look at when I
feel like when I look at my life before
and when I felt like I had to judge my
life compared to someone else's life it
was because I wasn't doing what I knew I
needed to do in my life
to live a meaningful life now wild
thoughts and crazy dreams sounds to me
like they're not worried about competing
as much as a worried about status and
that that is always going to be an issue
if you're worried about your status
compared to someone else's status that
is a losing game because even if you
become the president of the United
States like you're still there's still
another status that you're gonna be
chasing right and by the way if you
become the President of the United
States seemingly no matter who you are
is not a political answer here break any
president ever half the country just
likes you
yeah yeah I mean if you become earth
czar I mean it's you still you still
will always be searching for that next
that next status as soon as I become
earth czar I will outlaw onion and a lot
of people are gonna dislike me for that
as soon as you as soon as you wild
thoughts and crazy dreams as soon as you
start to live up to your own standards
and you start to feel more complete you
will you will honestly by default stop
looking for that status I mean this
isn't like a you know magic bullet
answer meaning that you're never gonna
want the Porsche or the Lamborghini
however when your life feels complete
when you start to feel more complete and
you do that by living up to your values
and beliefs but by living up to your
standards you you are
looking less externally for things too
to make you happy so so so the so that's
in order to get over the the addiction
of status you have to you have to live
up to your own standards that that is
how you that to me like that is how I
stopped looking at my status compared to
other people's I think an additional
pithy answer there is worry more about
impressing yourself than others yeah
absolutely
you